[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys where
nick
i suck dick is that what it is oh no no
no no no no no oh wait that is your line
i thought it was like we suck
we like titties yeah is it is it me or
us colleen i know you like sucking dick
i like sucking on titties oh yeah
because it rhymes with my name and jio
doesn't have a penis yeah barton titties
rhymes as well we need a new one
honestly i think from now on i'm just
gonna point to somebody and see what
they say
it's a fun improv game hey pointing me
well now you're ready for it but hey
welcome back to this episode of careful
boys where's steve nick sucks dick
hey that's pretty good
shout out to your boy
it does still rhyme when steve has it
well aren't we happy that ryan's here
yeah
ryan how's it going every time ryan's
here that means we're still alive
because ryan still has a job
but do you know that michael hasn't
killed us yet when i get the call she
and this is ryan h my first thought
actually is ryan higa oh and you're like
yay
i'm like he's gonna come in
i've gotten that before and people are
just like you're not him i'm like i'm
not hey why doesn't ryan h come he
probably can so what the [ __ ]
i heard he doesn't leave his house hook
it up vegas [ __ ]
too though that's what i heard he
doesn't oh yeah by the way yeah we call
behind cameras you need to bring graham
steph in here because you're just on his
show trying to wait you're on graham
stephanie yeah he was on the iced coffee
hour he's great he did all two-hour
podcast about how jk failed
it was really good
when did this happen uh maybe like last
month or a few yeah i was like oh thank
god for crypto my other businesses would
be [ __ ]
i guess this thing's over
[Laughter]
i was like oh wait i got a call sheet
today i guess we're going next week for
some reason damn come on you let's let's
be serious we know you're here for gas
money and food that's it baby and a
little bit alcohol you know i don't want
to spend money on anything but crypto
everyone knows about me so yeah you know
what's funny is that none of us need to
be here like be here but uh excuse me
this is my number one job oh really i
didn't know that okay so we're here for
ryan and ebony
[Applause]
we were just talking about this earlier
of like everyone's got other [ __ ] going
on but we're still like coming here as a
group to like have fun it's fun it's a
nice break but then we want to go harder
here in the comic world but then we go
oh wait i got these other things
i got to be careful we're careful boys
yeah right well i say wild [ __ ] back at
like when i'm not you know here and it
gets me in trouble yeah you forget what
you see yeah it gets me in trouble do we
bring that out of everybody i think so
because when we're here dude we're um
we're on the go we're saying rangers
what is that boys it's mad libs bro i'm
grabbing something from here so grab
here and then i'll end up saying some
[ __ ] that's like
inappropriate and then in the wrong
setting find inappropriate he has to
explain to his wife he's not gay yeah
dude every day bro and she already has
questions about it yeah
a lot of stuff she already has she just
burst in the door she's like i'm naked
when she watches this video she's like
why the [ __ ] is this the tagline why is
this the runner huh yeah why is the
runner you're kind of gay and i'm i
don't know what to tell her it's just
that simple one say hey uh honey i know
that you've been you know really
enjoying yourself on jk news and stuff
but i just don't like it when uh anthony
does the whole care boys and then you
say you like dick or something and i'm
like babe you don't get it it's for the
bit for the boys i do have to say
genuinely i'm glad that you're here i
very much enjoy your company yeah nick
was a great great great great call you
know well let's not let's not talk about
this no we're gonna talk about it it
makes you uncomfortable nick is nick is
so like comfortable with us yeah he just
kind of seemingly like he just came in
and no one noticed him yeah yeah
nobody's there he'll notice no one's no
this is nick but he's [ __ ] that's how
that's how much it works my name is
michael what's up he just picks up a
check that bounces
because it's over according to graham
steffen podcast it's [ __ ] done he's
just bad-mouthing jk [ __ ] done dude
that was a good podcast though was it i
didn't remember what happened what were
you saying to uh stefan graham about how
like jk was like done or failed i just
made that up dude i don't even know if
devin graham that's seven grams
no i was just letting him tell the
graham crackers i was just letting his
questions i guess lead the podcast
because he actually didn't really know
too much at all so i think at first he
thought i was a bodybuilder he called
him a [ __ ] uh fitness guru yeah
yeah
he actually got his [ __ ] what he
wanted i get some respect
i've been calling her i've been dunking
that shot for three years yeah i finally
dunk in that shot you know he finally
got i don't know how to dunk by the way
but i know how to shoot threes [ __ ] i
don't wanna shoot threes don't give that
shot baby making touchdowns happen in
the comments half of the comments were
like bart finally got his dream of being
a fitness guru really that's what the
comments said
why do you think you're not a fitness
guru no that's the best thing is you
find it that's why everyone says the
funny thing is his branding is a fitness
guru not a comedian so if you went on
his instagram you wouldn't you would not
know with a with a [ __ ] mic though
yeah right and that's why graham stefan
thought he was a fitness guy because of
the perception that you put out on your
[ __ ] instagram which is what i've
been calling for years he still doesn't
course correct
he just does the same [ __ ] a little bit
true well i guess i'm a fitness group
[Applause]
but it seemed like um
you you you surprised him you said or
like yeah because he was like he was
like oh so tell me about like
bodybuilding and i'm actually not a
bodybuilder
so i think he was just trying to
understand and he's like wait you're a
comedian because i didn't want to bring
your canadian on the show damn dude
graham stefan wings it huh no yeah he
has the opposite policy that we have so
you know we come in here like we miss
each other so we just start shooting
this [ __ ] and actually like the stuff
that's off the off the camera it's
actually really good but we're just
connecting and talking when we're there
it's like uh like let's say his his boy
would ask me a question
like everything was like save it for
camera save it for camera so i even had
questions for him and
uh i just said it so it was just silent
while everyone's just like oh geez like
setting seven setting everything up he's
smart because we wasted all the good
content when the cameras aren't on so he
so i think we wanted
to talk about the real gay sex and
juicing right yeah the stuff that i
really do yeah so i think he really
wanted to explore and discover
on the camera so he just didn't even
know so he already started off i'm sorry
this shit's like authentic super out
there yeah ours is like totally scripted
i'm not a bodybuilder i'm a power
powerlifter actually that kind of came
here like accidentally because i started
off in like youtube comedy and then he
was just like what what what and i'm
just i'm just kind of painting him the
whole picture like the last 15. i do
agree with steve though in terms of like
what you
present
if i didn't follow more of your ig
stories right because your ig stories
you get a little bit more comedic with
some stuff even though all your ig
stories are still [ __ ] lifting
exactly bro
it's [ __ ] lifting and running around
in your [ __ ] black same boxers always
shooting [ __ ] nerf guns comes in a
pack of 12. they are good pretty good
that being said it's a good deal that's
a good deal that being said though like
joe might be the only person
who via instagram
is the same guy on instagram i don't
think so
brother that's true brother
[Laughter]
joe joe chose right now to be
inauthentic
with just tama brother he never says
that ever because even with steve
secondly won steve on instagram is we're
like like trolling everybody [ __ ]
idiots i'm i'm going broke wait let me
like i love that so hard i'm not very
good at crypto apparently what do you
guys okay so we have a shorts lunch then
i'm hanging out with my family with my
kids okay like the top three the top two
right there you're like working out with
jk working out you're working out you're
working you're working you're you're
exercising you're lifting your butt you
can't even see himself you're lifting no
that's a funny video dude you're doing
jitsu fitness guru with a sense of humor
you're
jiu
and a family and a family like we get it
you have a family you're a fitness guru
who does that comedy on the side
very lucrative my yeah my instagram i'd
still treat it as if like i'm
there for my friends so like i'm posting
[ __ ] just so so you guys can see it i'm
like this fraud right
whereas for example
i'm trying to market to you guys nick
the ear here is close to 10k followers
let's pump those numbers up okay let's
get them to 10k all you patrons out
there could just hook a brother up with
the k for ketamine and if you guys need
fitness guru advice go to bar
kwon how does it feel to be competitors
in the game but still sit next to each
other you know uh every day i just take
shots on barbell brigade behind the
camera
don't hurt my feelings no actually i
love everything barbell brigade does
really this is really you dude look how
big those ears are bro
this is a weird [ __ ] thing you get
some lift on that oh so the cauliflower
happened from back then huh dude i used
to get mate i used to get [ __ ]
shredded as a kid you look like a mouse
kids used to make fun of me for my ears
all the time and i had no idea why when
i look back at old pictures i'm like oh
i totally know why you look like [ __ ]
mickey mouse comically big like they
were like dumbo you can fly with those
things
do you think you would have eventually
grown into those or i think
this will bart's comment damn you can
get directv with them
it's your [ __ ] 1990s oh okay bart is
on brad with his comments yeah yeah cuz
sometimes his comments though yeah
amazing
who finds that you're [ __ ] whack you
[ __ ] that's part i don't even remember
writing those things you can't get
direct tv
i was like yeah dude i've heard that my
whole [ __ ] life but it's a new
material what's the part i know and then
i watch this cat only working out and
drinking milk
i don't even remember writing those
things
on every post that i have bart has some
sort of [ __ ] always dude bart can't
wait to troll the comments today's video
is brought to you by amazon music amazon
music has more than 10
million
free podcasts and over thousands of
music stations can i believe that so
many sounds so many so many sounds but
amazon music it's not just for like
podcasts like this one they have music
they have a ton of playlists they have
so many stations you can stream from
it's pretty uh extensive library of
music too and no matter what you're
listening to you can go hands-free all
you have to say is hey alexa play dance
rock music
red polka christian love songs death
metal love songs get the app and enjoy
free listening everywhere on your
favorite devices and best of all there's
no credit card or subscription required
so go check it out there's so much music
on there thousands of music stations
tens of millions of free podcasts just
go to amazon.com
otr pod to check it out lots of great
content is so fun it's easy it's
hands-free amazon.com o-t-r-p-o-d
oh my last picture i put up he was like
you know you're [ __ ] gay dude that's
not your wife
it's like it's like happy birthday tim
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly so funny
this is a front this is a fake marriage
that's what he commented
and then you have to explain to your
wife what the [ __ ] that
means it did you read it probably she's
probably waiting for me to want to go
home right now my favorite [ __ ] is like
i'm on a meme page or whatever and i see
bart's comment or some [ __ ] and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
that's that's one of the better ways to
learn about like how a social influencer
or somebody online actually is like look
at the way they comment on other
people's [ __ ] versus look at the [ __ ]
that they post themselves right because
we were just talking about this on your
podcast like if people
if i didn't have jk specifically i
probably wouldn't even have like a
talking platform and then people would
judge me only on my choreography or my
audience on your dance right that's all
right yeah not your thoughts but the
thing is like i'm i'm very uh call it a
gemini split personality whatever like i
use dance to express the things that i
can't do like vocally or verbally right
here we i'm an idiot i'm a fool i get it
but
in dance i i love choreographing to like
beautiful music it takes my breath away
giving me some sort of emotional stir
feeling you know something that like i
can
express myself in some sort of ethereal
way and and sometimes people come up to
me all right and and they're inspired or
impacted by my dance because it's so
deep in that sense
but then they have no [ __ ] idea that
i'm just an idiot like i'm just a goon
and that there's a whole total i'm like
dr jekyll mr hi whatever when people
brand you in the box they can't see
outside of that
they'd be like what this dude jacks off
mr rogers you know what i mean like
that's not the jump that i would have
made
oh [ __ ] joe biden jackson off too i
don't know
don't fight it for sure don't judge me
change my own perception
about my artichoke oh dude this new jag
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] you jack off man no way me too
that's how joe relayed though guys you
gotta listen noise yeah yeah yeah yeah i
agree i mean humans are very uh they
have a lot of different faces you know
what i mean
different no but somebody who weaves at
anthony dancing doesn't understand that
andy's also like okay bro i got
5k let's de-gen some [ __ ]
and i go on zoom with him and he's like
buying some [ __ ] that i've never heard
of in my life and he's like let's go not
true not true i don't buy [ __ ]
that's the whole point that social media
is not
specifically intended to be a perfect
reflection of who you are it's it's
meant to be yeah exaggerated and that's
okay there's nothing wrong with that
right if it wasn't
hey then curated [ __ ] then curated
it
to be curated
to be curious
you have to curate it because you're
literally curating it and you're putting
it all out there you're why they think
that you're why the joke lands every
time and gets the laugh in the room
every [ __ ] time it's because of you
it's because you click yeah post you're
like yeah yeah
every time dude all your stories don't
read my comments then
exactly
those
screenshots
of them [ __ ] make a compilation dude
that's [ __ ] that'll be funny we know
people walls of your gym that you own
yeah i do i do think in respect this is
actually funny because like you know for
the last couple years remember how
social influencers have uh been getting
either harassed or feeling depression
because of like you know or people in
general who follow other people right
are kind of like these people have
perfect lies why is my life they're so
stupid they believe that [ __ ] that's
what i'm saying it's like yo everybody
needs to understand that like it's fully
fully curated i'm not saying fake no yes
i'm just saying it's curious one section
of your life you know how many people
are out there on [ __ ] instagram
perfect couple and they're fighting
during the whole [ __ ] trip that
should happen so many times that sounds
like that sounds personal but
when no but when you hit the when you
hit the record button on the vlog right
not doing that while you and geo are
[ __ ] going at it yeah you know you're
like you clean it up first
we can't curate [ __ ] i really want to
right but exactly i know you would
actually sometimes but sometimes things
get taken out of context so i understand
their point of view too but exactly he's
awesome like i want to show everything
[ __ ] that [ __ ] my favorite is when i
watch certain people's vlogs and then
they have a camera of them waking up out
of bed and then they like ah and they do
that thing and you forget they're like
oh they have to set that up before they
do they were like this they [ __ ] hit
that [ __ ] with their toe and then they
went ah
my favorite is when i've been to my
friends marriage interventions and then
i watched their vlog on monday and
they're like perfect lighting in love i
can't love i can't believe i'm i'm in a
dream fairy tale marriage intervention
yeah
tell me what the [ __ ] is a marriage
intervention dude so that they don't get
a divorce it's like you do that as a
group you know yeah why are you guys
there friends show up and then they're
going through their 911 and then we're
all there to be like no it's fine
because uh hopefully it works out
it's that fun too yeah it sounds about
that funny it's like is there alcohol
involved no damn
it's like the cleanup crew on 911. it's
about that fun yep
what's under this rock oh god damn oh
god [ __ ] damn okay wow holy [ __ ]
that's the worst thing i've ever seen
time to get the other rock what's up to
the next rock yeah yeah we're not ready
to lift up that rock yeah
i'm not emotionally stable enough why
are you guys doing it as a group though
can we not do this anymore at all okay
we have to clean up okay how many
marriage interventions have you been to
too many so more than one yeah oh [ __ ]
is it is it just a natural phase of or
is that just a is that just a your
girlfriend it's what i get for being
accessible as a friend
[Laughter]
is that why people still because asian
people hide their feelings they don't
talk about it they just bury that [ __ ]
if it was white people it would be about
diddling
all right oh god it wasn't about that
that's not what we were asking
that took a left that's your answer pal
that's just the reality of these things
white people intervention is stop
[ __ ] your sister
see
a little past diddling
i think i earned that joke what's the
official definition of deadly just
someone on the same page as you oh it's
everything you're thinking
all the above and and more it's just not
good it's probably not a rigid rigid
definition you're going to penis
oh wow sometimes everything and more
like you said that's what the uncle
thinks he's doing
notice he said the uncle oh okay yeah i
understand what deadly means now that's
all you have to say but it's crazy
because a lot of people still don't know
that all this [ __ ] is just manipulated
yeah like from
you know filters to everything
yeah and it's just entertainment also i
feel like content creators don't really
help because everybody's trying to be
more genuine and more authentic because
that's their thing you know that's their
[ __ ] brand is like oh we're so you
know authentic or whatever and so
everyone's like buys into that brand as
part of like what you're watching
everything is authentic to a certain
point cause not everyone's gonna come
like a chain russian show everything
yeah like applebee's same ingredients
but it's the same execution are you
eating good in the neighborhood
[Laughter]
ryan's a big house that's what i'm
saying man it smells good drink have you
ever gotten gone applebee's just for the
bar
no is it good it's good it is everything
you're imagining and
the last time i did that for shits and
giggles there was some dude that was
going on about the [ __ ] bible to the
bartender and we could not get this
[ __ ] bartender's attention he was
like oh and then in exodus all of these
things happen we're like i just want to
pay wait the bartender was in huh yeah
he was like cleaning up and like facing
away from us like talking to this guy
about [ __ ]
page
yeah and this dude was the guy that was
like drinking was [ __ ] plastered like
this dude was like
this dude was dead drunk pastor huh he's
gonna dui later like for sure first
that's kind of tied to like super [ __ ]
up
this is what i gotta do i gotta talk
about the bible with this applebee's
bargain i have to convert this [ __ ]
bartender i went to an outback
steakhouse bar one time
very fun and did you get a blooming
onion oh no no i went to the bar but i
could have i could but uh but the
regulars were there and it was very
interesting to see how they interact
with each other and how they like flirt
with each other and [ __ ] because they're
all like 45 years old alcoholics and
like
super outback steak likes 10 years older
than us 5 30. yeah exactly what about a
cheesecake factory bar that's a little
classier a little classy how about just
get a six-pack at 7-eleven and go behind
the dumpster and drink it with homeless
people okay that's really funny but
that's something we're not posting on
social media
that could be joe's new niche
check my feed later
this is off-brand you shouldn't post it
okay
okay mom
i don't say hey people human beings are
super complicated and complex
everybody's complex it's not about evil
it's not about right wrong just know
that when you [ __ ] follow bart
he's a fitness guru
not a comedian
in the comments it's a community does he
understand yeah
he is a comedic dichotomy of man he
wears comedy hat and just don't forget
when he was young his [ __ ] ears could
collect direct tv
and let's be real they still probably
can you know yeah but it's like kind of
fuzzy because you know yeah yeah like
you won't get channels seven through
eight but like even through eight
people complain about the service
people say the service sucks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you